buon pomeriggio e buon pomeriggio a
tutti anche da parte mia in mezzo a
tutte queste persone straordinarie
io e con storie incredibili o
rappresenta semplicemente la banalissima
e banalissima comunità dei docenti degli
accademici e oltretutto anche un po
pipponi come qui vedo tanti ragazzi
purtroppo sanno a mia discolpa posso
dire che ho cercato di interpretare il
mio ruolo in maniera diciamo così
ragionevolmente imprenditoriale ecco
sono da sempre appassionato di
tecnologie digitali di disfatta p's che
quindi sono stato fra i primi in italia
quindici anni fa seconda metà degli anni
90 a cercare di utilizzare internet per
fare un po di business e in particolare
di fare primi a lanciare livello
mondiale ufficialmente prodotti di
abbigliamento collo che ufficiale delle
delle griffe
ecco sto parlando il 98 ben prima di
yoox federico marchetti
ecco peccato che a differenza di vista è
anche i primi a richiudere fallimento
abbiamo anche cercato e quindi
differenza del federico che ha creato
una società quotata incredibile ho anche
giocato in quel periodo lì di bb fare
una delle più importanti quotazioni da
noi in borsa a milano una ip o una
quotazione da 1,5 miliardi di euro ecco
da poco più di trent'anni non contavo
neanche peccato che fosse nel luglio del
2000 quattro mesi dopo il crollo di
tutti i mercati mondiali ecco anche lì
troppi incredibile è che un fratello
proprio per questo ecco da questo track
record assolutamente potente io gli
credo il varo ecco vi parlo di ballo di
questo il coraggio di intraprendere
intraprendere proprio il significato
della parola il coraggio di provare a
lanciare iniziative imprenditoriale di
fare l'imprenditore e utilizzo un po
questo questo slogan che sto utilizzando
un po da tanto anche perché è un po la
mia missione negli ultimi anni come
accademico back to the feature cosa cosa
significa capirete fra pochissimo in
realtà probabilmente molti di voi
l'hanno già colto allora mi metto un
cappello serio e mette un cappello di
tra virgolette pseudo esperto di
economia mondiale
vi faccio la considerazione
molto puntuale che ho la certezza
peccato che in italia se ne parli molto
molto poco in un'economia matura come la
nostra come quello italiano come quello
europea come quella nord americana la
crescita economica una parte consistente
della crescita economica
misuriamo la pura come pil e misuriamo
la come occupazione deriva dalla
capacità di creare nuove imprese le
cosiddette startups qui e senza voler
fare troppo troppo ma regano ecco senza
accettare come al solito sempre solo
ecco il fenomeno oltreoceano
in realtà questi numeri purtroppo ce ne
sono pochi invece erano in europa
questi numeri sono incredibili no danno
un messaggio molto chiaro e molto chiaro
una un milione i nuovi posti di lavoro
vengono creati ogni anno dalle
cosiddette start up per questo la
guardate un po gli altri due il 95 per
cento di fatto dall'art la totalità la
quasi totalità dei nuovi posti di lavoro
vengono sono stati creati negli stati
uniti da aziende che sono nate negli
ultimi cinque anni il 40 per cento del
pil è stato prodotto da aziende che 30
anni fa non esistevano allora cosa ci
sono le conseguenze di questi numeri
per il nostro paese che se non capiamo
questo se non crea 19 imprese non
creeremo posti di lavoro non creiamo il
nuovo pil e siamo destinati a fare la
fine che stiamo destinare che stiamo di
fatto facendo bene e e l'italia è
l'italia in questo contesto perché
indietro perché indietro indietro
maniera incredibile indietro su
qualunque tipo indicatore quinnell cito
uno dei tanti no semplicemente guardando
gli investimenti in start up high tech
quindi quelli dei settori più evoluti
abbiamo quasi da vergognarsi un settimo
sotto rispetto alla francia che più o
meno se avete un pil quasi comparabile
al nostro poco più alto a un quinto
rispetto in germania e gli ok ma con un
quindi catore da questo tipo di gap
perché uno si dice perché questo è come
potrebbe dire perché non siamo
culturalmente propensi a fare gli
imprenditori a fare le start up giusto è
no e qui viene back to the feature non è
così perché fra le poche cose che siamo
famosi nel mondo almeno di quelle poche
cose da qui vantarsi
e proprio alla sua incredibile storia
imprenditoriale del secolo scorso
ecco perché è stata studiata in tutti i
sacri testi anche quelli americani la
nostra amico imprenditorialità che ha
fatto nel secolo scorso un paese
assolutamente sottosviluppato
assolutamente indietro rispetto alla
maggior parte dei paesi europei con una
percentuale ancora di economia basato
sul primario elevatissima l'ha
trasformato nella quinta potenza globale
il fenomeno dei distretti industriali e
allora che è successo che è successo
perché perché abbiamo annichilito
abbiamo nichelato questa cultura è
successo le ultimi 30 anni 40 anni la
generazione a generazione i nostri
genitori l'ha distrutta annichilita
l'atrofizzazione per sostituire questa
cultura ad intraprendere con quale
cultura
consentitemi consentitemi la cultura del
posto fisso
la cultura del contratto a tempo
indeterminato la cultura e parlo da
docente e quindi anche del master la
cultura del fare carriera in azienda
peccato che contratto a tempo
indeterminato e fare carriera azienda
presuppongono che cosa esistenza
dell'azienda presuppongono aziende e
organizzazioni a tempo indeterminato che
non è che non esistono
lo scenario che stiamo vivendo c'è l'ha
sbattuto paurosamente addosso non
esistono le aziende l'organizzazione
tempo indeterminato allora lo così
facendo deleghiamo semplicemente ad
altri a quelli che avrebbero perché
dovrebbero farci fare carriera quelli
che dovrebbero darci il contratto a
tempo indeterminato il vero ruolo noi
siamo passivi noi percorriamo una strada
che qualcun altro ci sta aprendo è qual
è l'effetto è questo e poi siamo in
balia di aziende che chiudono le aziende
che decidono di trasferire i propri
investimenti dall'italia in qualche
altro paese aziende estere che dopo aver
provato il nostro contesto prendono e se
la danno bene questa è la cultura che
abbiamo sostituito ma per andare un
pochino più ai tempi correnti e non
considera solo il secolo scorso
volevo in realtà a dare un po di un po
di dvd e ottimismo
un pochino di luce di ottimismo
conoscete bene siede un grazie lo
conoscete questi lorenzo thione andrea
vaccari mito lo mele fabio carnevale
antonio tomarchio
vi porto facce facce che sono dietro da
venturi imprenditore incredibile nel mio
settore quindi vuole essere esaustivo in
tutto il mondo nel mio settore mio
settore quello delle tecnologie digitali
dell'innovazione digitale oltretutto
consentitemi questa piccola appunto
campanilismo vi ho portato facce che
sono passate per il politecnico di
milano
che sono stati studente al politecnico
di milano ve ne sono persone che son
riuscito a fare cose incredibili
nonostante tutto e negli scorsi anni il
faccio qualche esempio a lorenzo thione
di milano poi purtroppo fra quelli che
alle amministrazioni ti ha creato una
società power7 venduta a microsoft bing
è alla base del motore di ricerca
semantico di microsoft 300 milioni di
dollari
andrea vaccari e del ragazzotto andrea
consentimi di giovane politecnico va in
silicon valley crea grimsey comprata da
da facebook un paio di anni fa
vitolo mele vitolo mele creatore founder
di job rapino nel 2006 una delle realtà
europee più interessante è venduto
all'anno scorso 50 per cento della ta
punto 44 per cento ad un editore inglese
per circa 30 milioni di euro li possiede
ancora il 50 per cento fabio carnevale
co founder di bravofly volagratis penso
che la rete utilizzate no secondo in
europa secondo in europa
il trans a un miliardo di euro società è
nata con 50mila euro nel 2006 abbiamo
antonio tomarchio questo scappato quindi
anche lui che ha preso sette milioni di
euro l'anno scorso persona incredibile
che al passi ha inventato una piccola
cosina nono tempo per spiegarla che oggi
si trova su 250 milioni di smartphone
nel mondo questo negli ultimi 24 mesi e
poi abbiamo ancora e poi abbiamo ancora
qui o qualche altro nome per fabio
volanti che ha inventato né venduta al
grande azienda americana bensì software
e fine giusto per abbiamo alessandro
fracassi cofano di mutuionline una delle
pochissime start up quotate bene allora
qual è il messaggio e con questo e con
questo chiudo in realtà il messaggio è
che alla fine anche in italia queste
storie si possono si possono fare il
tema vero è adesso lottare contro la
cultura che le ha soffocato qualcosa di
importante proprio in questo periodo sta
capitando negli ultimi due anni avete
sentito perché finalmente mai come in
questi anni si parla di start è un po
tutti i livelli a livello politico a
livello di miglia ecco qualcosa qualcosa
sta accadendo io la sensazione che siamo
un po di fronte ad un ragionevole nuovo
rinascimento alla parola rifacimento è e
pomposa no forse più
grande di quello che però forse siamo in
una situazione in cui qualcosa si sta
muovendo e forse ritorniamo a recuperare
quindi alla nostra cultura
imprenditoriale e con questo chiudo
rivolgendosi soprattutto a voi ragazzi
e chiaro che oggi e vedo circo migliaia
di studenti l'anno è chiaro che oggi
chiunque di voi che qualunque persona da
ragazzina di 15 anni allo studente
unitario di 20 al manager di 35 ha di
fronte un insieme di strada e
tipicamente molte strade solo sarebbe
più spianate quella della convenzione
quella della storia non diventare
appunto manager fare certe carriere e
cody oggi abbiam capito che queste
strada un certo punto ha portato in un
burrone non portano lontano
allora c'è un altro tipo di di altro
tipo di approccio che quello di crearsi
la propria strada di andare magari
all'inizio sembra come nella vignetta
sembra un pochino più più difficile
sembra non portare un granché ma ho la
sensazione che solo scoprendo questa
strada e mulinando le masse non infetta
i nomi di prima no a migliaia e migliaia
di imprenditore riusciremo a far
qualcosa per questo paese
grazie